vittima e oggi andremo a vedere delle
cose che sono molto più grandi di quanto
pensiamo
i migranti rimasta sono rimasta
scioccata non ho voluto vedere le altre
perché voglio vedere le stelle
poi è come sempre di conventi dovrete
scrivere qual è quella che vi ha giocato
di più potrete mettere il time stamp
quindi il minuto di quella che vi ha
giocato di più lasciato un bel live se
volete vedere né altri mettetevi comodi
pop corn b10 tempi abbiamo
berlusconi.l'ho letto ho cercato perché
a me sembra un castoro castor org in
realtà è un animale che si chiama
bombato ed è un animale dell'australia
con poche ora sembra piccolissimo se
proprio piccolo piccolo invece guardo
conto è grande è sempre uno grandi di
pieri motorino e lì deve gigante numero
due corse scritto allora in pratica è
una sfera e dentro a tantissime altre
palline c'è scritto questo è quante
volte quante terre quanti pianeta terra
stanno dentro il sole è assurdo perché
ti fa pensare quanto è piccolo il
pianeta terra il pianeta terra
in confronto al sole quindi vedete tutte
queste palline blu rappresentano il
pianeta terra ed è quante volte si
sarebbe dentro al sole enorme
incredibile queste sono le mani di un
gorilla
un aspetto nuovo luci nantes e non
pensavo così grande il pdl col possono
pure di strette di spiazzati da vicino
le mani di gorilla e sono molto più
gravi di quanto pensassi
questo è il cuore di una balena è finta
ovviamente però fa capire quanto è
grande allora secondo per corona quasi
una persona quindi questa è la grandezza
del cuore di una balena di lui c'è
scritto una balena blu
il cuore è così grande e o soggetti e
piante immagina la balena in confronto
con the g
è incredibile davvero enormi sono
scioccata
questa è una tartaruga gigante la rabbia
non leicester becks intanto quindi una
tartaruga di mare marina gigante e
correnti non pensavo fossero così grandi
sembrava tutto fatto da quanto è grande
e di una donna viola e gigante
impaziente trovarvi la logica starter
dato sui grande se si può anche
cavalcare una tartaruga così non certo
non calre gaeta spero che può venire
però era veramente
precisiamo forme incredibile fao che
fortunata questa ragazza che la b
prossimo a come comparazione quello in
cui siamo è un bus anno quello lì dietro
e un bus
questo è un camion gigante ho un mio zio
contro il grande questo cambio i camion
della miniera c'è se non ci fosse stato
il bus dietro non avrei mai immaginato
che questo bus fosse così grande perché
da questo caso questo camion forse così
grande e dalla foto non sembra che stia
tanto grande ma il punto vero muscolo di
atri confronto infatti c'era un altro un
altro camion di più avanti per la
comparazione io avrei un sacco di paura
stare dietro questo mostro gigante
ottobre il pacco di paura tua casella
zampe gli artigli di un'aquila in
confronto alla mano di un essere umano
out nova bhaskaran scioccata è grande
quasi quanto una mano e gli arti sono
lunghissimo in un incredibile ora
capisco come fanno perché le aquile
cacciano anche animali di taglia grazie
alla cinese e ho sempre pensato ma come
campo vanno a tirarli su insomma con le
zampe e vedendo casi zampe si sa non
sono delle tortine apparati che attiri
c'è incredibile l'aquila e gigante
noi la vediamo un po che sembra
piccolino ma è enorme l'acqua prossimo
qua c'è il titanic a confronto con una
noce la prima sera moderna allora io
pensavo che evitare che fosse la nave
più grande gigante sapete quando lo vedi
non solo nel film anche nelle foto è
enorme ma guarda la nave da crociera è
molto grande enorme uovo l'avrebbe
schiacciata completamente titanic
lacrime da crociera un terzo di
larghezza rispetto a una nave moderna
sono scioccata il gigantesca e
incredibile ma che si sta per e di come
ci siete mai stati in una crociera non
esiste un messaggi scriveteci come
dentro insomma come se ti rendi conto di
quanto è gigante se riesci a esplorare
la tuta scriveteci un po le vostre
esperienze nei commenti che comunque è
scioccante questo davvero prossimo qua
abbiamo poi cosa non so se siano veri
spero di no anche se il fatto che siano
in uno studio verso le delle linari of
horses ruberi spero di no ma non lo so
comunque sono dei polmoni di cavallo
completamente gonfiati o c'è al cavallo
grandissimo così però non te ne rendi
conto dai video dalle foto situazione
davanti si però wow incredibile dei
polmoni di cavallo così grande
a parte che il cavallo è uno dei minima
di preferirlo sembra una creatura tv
l'unicorno lissi ma gli manca solo il
corno però è bellissimo il cavallo e
quindi vedere che ha dei polmoni dei
grandi abbiamo il questa coar notro be
allora questo è un utero tauro quindi
dinosauro che è esistito e scrivo questa
al quarto sono troppi ed è comprato un
uomo alto un metro e ottanta quindi un
uomo anche altro incredibile è il nucleo
di animale insomma il suo grado lanteri
e meego ha vestito anche se non esiste
più però alla testa il becco ormi
assurto cioè non riesco a immaginarlo
esisteva davvero stava qua nella terra
buona norma allora se la luna fosse
rimpiazzato da da saturno quindi fa
vedere la differenza in grandezza o
sarebbero farm guasta e beneficata io
non mi fermo giusto così
altro che lui allora questa è una cometa
comparata alla città di los angeles
non pensavo fosse così grande qualità
ovviamente noi vediamo le stelle comete
infatti solo sorta di stima vediamo una
striscia di luce e wow
se cadesse una cometa sulla terra quindi
distruggerebbe un intera città
o forse anche di più
fa un po paura però anche incredibile
allora questa è un luogo state un lupo
comparata a dei coyote quindi ovviamente
queste sono i coyote e questa è questo e
il lupo non pensavo che dopo forse così
grande
wow massimo la piramide la grande
piramide di giza
quindi la piramide di giza comparata un
essere umano che sto vedendo lele
fermana equa
[Musica]
pazzesco deve essere bellino vederla ci
piacerebbe andare a vederla in si tifa
vista per esercizi e testati in egitto e
se l'avete vista
wow deve essere incredibile da vedere
allora prossimo c'è un coccodrillo di
acque salate
wow un mito ritenendo i brividi perché
prima doveva di cuore i coccodrilli e
vedere che sono così grandi
per me ma sempre affascinato il tocco di
una creatura bellissima però ovviamente
fa paura e quindi deve esserci questo
posto in cui ti puoi immergere dentro
dentro una teca
io non mi fiderei drive lo farei vai a
farti capire che cosa è il reso a
distruggerla quella sì e poi vedere il
coccodrillo da vicino a norma se volete
inghiottirebbe in un boccone allora
questa è la differenza entrambi quindi
sia qualche qua ci sono 10.000 dollari
nei frame b questi sono i biglietti da
cento invece in questi sono i biglietti
da un dollaro perché in americano i
biglietti per un dollaro quindi puoi
vedere la differenza cento sembrano
pochissimi verso i biglietti da un
dollaro sembra che states
cosa no non ci credo il possibile ma se
questa persona ti è passato davanti ogni
notte
io mi sarebbe venuto un infarto primo
perché non avrei capito che animale
andare di notte
qua è bellina e quasi un unicorno e
diceva un ricordo crociata giappone è
incredibile non sapendo che l'osce fosse
così grande anche voi oggi avete
imparato un sacco di grandezza a
ribadire a trovarti là davanti ti viene
un po le paure che sia molto buono come
animale potrebbe schiacciarla prossimo
abbiamo il david di michelangelo che io
l'ho visto dal b sì non me l'aspettavo
così grande e molto più grande di quanto
si pensa perché in foto sembrano tutte
piccole colibrì
l'unica cosa che invece il contrario
pensavo fosse più grande invece era più
piccola era la monna lisa era molto più
piccola
sarebbe uno si aspetta un quadro errori
sottoscritto quattro piccole 90 da
gigante in mezzo al contrario una un
obiettivo non lo manca una chiamata
africana gigante un cazzo mi sembra un
animale domenico gatto nell'occhiello i
pacchetti sono grandi ma che carriera
gigante inversa cancellati ed il in
braccio in casa lascia una scia enorme
cibava di la società liscia con tutta la
bancari da ora prima di averla come
animale domestico un giorno se le piazze
davvero innanzitutto il giardino cosa
non solo se maturo e così grande il
semaforo sempre piccolo vediamo sempre
tanto in alto alcuni sono tanto tanto in
alto e non tiene mai conto di quale la
grandezza di un semaforo questo in
questo caso di semaforo americano però
penso che i nostri siano grandi uguale e
cioè a queste contro una persona mi
sarei mai aspettato tutte le aspettative
sia in quello avevo già visto qualcuno
quando li sostituivano maniera
impressionante
sono rimasto impressionato perché avevo
visto quando lo sostituivano perché
l'avevo hanno smontato l'avevano
lasciato per terra quindi quando lo vedi
per terra ti rendi conto che non solo in
alto magari a volte ne rendi conto sono
le pale delle turbine eoliche allora
queste sono le pale eoliche che infatti
sono giganti sono molto più grandi di
quanto pensiate perché noi veniamo da
lontano sembrano gigante ma più ti
avvicini più giganti sono comunque in
questo caso è una di queste
la me o come si dice se una di queste
insomma è così grande uomo mi
impressiona valutando le cose sono in
alto non tre verbi
e bravo cassinate questa cosa altre
abbiamo gli aum ying che se non sbaglio
ho vinto il record lo conosco come
persona più alta al mondo
quindi questo ragazzo è alto sistema
airfit quanto è questo ragazzo qua e al
32 m 13 quindi un gigante gigantissimo
aurelia mobbing lo supera comunque aver
voluto mettere una persona di battaglia
normale capire la differenza alto molto
alto
i cartelli stradali o non ci credi
vedere da lontano
l'avevo mai pensato che cartelli
stradali sono gigantissimi perché li
vediamo in altissimo perché ci rendiamo
conto di quanto sono grandi
sono scioccata sì sì enorme enorme
quindi la prossima volta che vedrete i
semafori cartelli stradali che lecite
testate si rialza sono giganteschi
certo è l'albero più grande al mondo
guarda il tronco ma ci sono delle
persone e il tronco e questo sarà un
pioppo vivo ma se vuoi o non vuoi ma o
quando ero piccola piccola sono stata in
america visitare un parco di sequoie
antichissime ed erano grandissime non
penso fossero grandi quanto queste ma
erano giganti ed e incredibili
un'esperienza bellissima allora questo è
il teschio di un signore con prodi in
chiave comparata un lupo adulto cosa ci
chiama questo è così grande dalle foto
non sembra un maialino locale enorme
tutto questo enorme abbiamo visto che il
lupo è enorme lo stesso ma il cinghiale
tre volte più grande è in crisi ma manca
una manta gigante buono abbiamo viste un
po di ricordi sì ma mai così grandi cioè
di tutti è pazzesco poi a me
impressionano un sacco quando fanno
vedere il polpo gigante oggi anche la
casetta il calamaro gigante è
impressionante
tutto è lo scheletro di una zampa di
orso parata alla mano di essere umano
grande e pericoloso anche molto enorme
allora questo è un cavo di quelli
dell'elettricità che si mettono sotto
terra si 400 mila volte comparato con
una mano quindi sono enormi di diametro
di passare a corrente questa è una
balena è un tipo di balena amber
comparata con un suv che gli sta dando
la mano quindi la mano del sud rispetto
alla mano della balena erano tutte le
cose fateci sapere quali ha giocato di
più oro il cartello strada i più di
un'ora abbiamo giocato tutti è stato
troppo bello vedere tutte queste cose
che noi contiamo che rasafa molto più
piccola va a te politi ha cercate di
cocco drillo perché sappiamo che la
grande però non me l'aspettavo così a 4
casoli a stuzzicare il caso brano
preferito